buonasera buonasera voi non potete
vederlo da lì ma qui sulla mia sinistra
c'è un timer che mette un'ansia che voi
non avete non avete proprio idea quella
il tempo poi abbiamo lo spazio questo
cerchio rosso
io ho davvero paura fare questo
movimento non so cosa potrebbe succedere
mi comunque spazio e tempo che sono
quelle che canti chiamava le categorie
le forme a priori della conoscenza sono
quelle quelle forme appunto attraverso
le quali noi ci orientiamo nel mondo e
se di spazio ne abbiamo già parlato di
quanto siamo insignificanti nello spazio
che abbiamo attorno
io credo che sia anche questione di
concentrarci sul tempo perché alla fin
dei conti è tutta davvero questione di
tempo se voi ci pensate il primo membro
della nostra famiglia
il primo mini de quindi ha fatto la sua
comparsa sulla terra intorno alla 7
milioni di anni fa
almeno sono queste le ultime scoperte
questi tempi che noi di cui noi talmente
disponiamo mentre il primo appartenente
alla nostra specie di cui noi siamo gli
ultimi sopravvissuti siamo l'ultima
varietà sopravvissuta della specie homo
quindi l'uomo habilis ha vissuto in un
periodo geologico che noi chiamiamo clio
ce ne è che corrisponde a 2,7 milioni di
anni fa
poi se ci sono stati una serie di eventi
un po sfortunati siamo giunti fino alla
nostra specie homo sapiens e alla quale
al qualcuno anche aggiunto un altro
sapiens per rafforzare l'idea che
qualcosa no la sappiamo in fin dei conti
me qualcosa davvero lo sappiamo e siamo
sapiens sapiens
ma io mi chiedo davvero così cos'è che
sappiamo noi molti identificano l'uomo
moderno per il fatto di essere un
produttore di cose voi sapete tutti la
rivoluzione scientifica la rivoluzione
industriale
l'uomo moderno produce produce c'è chi
produce c'è chi consuma
vanno moderne un produttore di cose un
fabbricatore di cose però chi dice
questo non dice tutta la verità
l'uomo è sempre stato un fabbricatore
con faber
e come l'uomo anche altri animali
possiedono la capacità di fabbricare un
determinato tipo di strumenti che gli
serve in determinati contesti per poter
sopravvivere
l'uomo non è da meno da questo punto di
vista però per quanto ne sappiamo
l'uomo è l'unico essere in grado di
costruire un determinato tipo di
strumenti e questi strumenti sono i
concetti e in questo molto probabilmente
avviene perché l'uomo è l'unico essere
in grado di articolare un linguaggio
molti uomini di articolare un linguaggio
al partire dal quale poi noi costruiamo
appunto questi concetti e il velo dei
concetti e che con i concetti noi
abbiamo costruito tutta la realtà che
abbiamo attorno tutto quanto è costruito
su concetti
pensate alla letteratura all'arte la
religione la scienza la filosofia e
persino il sistema pensionistico
anche se poi le due cose non vanno molto
d'accordo ma con i concetti siamo
arrivati sulla luna la nostra
aspirazione ad arrivare sulla luna è
venuta da lì la divina commedia
il trittico del giardino delle delizie
di boxe tutto costruito su concetti e su
concetti sono state costruite anche le
cose più nefaste più spregevoli che
abbiamo fatto
le guerre e le persecuzioni
l'antisemitismo e lo sfruttamento
dissennato del pianeta di questo pianeta
che davvero stranamente fragile
beh chi diceva che in realtà noi viviamo
in un mondo che abbiamo costruito con la
nostra mente avete presente matrix
beh chi diceva questo non ha tutta la
ragione del mondo ma non non ha neanche
tanto torto noi viviamo in un mondo
immaginario in un mondo che abbiamo
costruito
ed è attraverso questi ordini immaginari
che non riusciamo a vivere in questo
mondo viviamo proprio nella tana del
bianconiglio e solo questo e questo è
l'unico modo che noi conosciamo
per poterci vivere su questo pianeta
quindi noi in realtà siamo dei
costruttori
però siamo dei costruttori di idee degli
abitanti delle idee che costruiamo molti
di voi ricorderanno la teoria delle idee
di platone sono queste idee sulla base
delle quali sono state costruite le cose
del mondo
però queste idee platone che fa le mette
in un altro orizzonte in un ordine
diverso che è quello della realtà che
noi viviamo tutti i giorni perché non
serviva un filosofo prey per dirlo per
capirlo la nostra realtà e corruttibile
brutta è degenerata e in costante
mutamento mentre il mondo in cui devono
stare le idee che sono queste queste
questi modelli universali deve essere
perfetto così come l'oro le idee sono
perfette incorruttibili e chi più ne ha
più ne metta
però questo dal mio punto di vista può
essere al di là delle varie
interpretazioni che vengono fatte che
sono tutte molto molto valide può essere
visto anche come un modo per spiegare la
costante tensione che anima l'uomo come
sempre teso a ricercare quelle idee a
cercare di metterle in pratica in questo
mondo quindi a cercare di rendere questo
mondo un po più perfetto non al livello
delle re ma cercare di avvicinarsi a
quella perfezione
quindi la storia dell'uomo dell'uomo
come specie sta tutta in questo sforzo
in questo sforzo costante e forse mai
raggiungibile di poter ricreare
riprendere le idee metterle in questo
mondo però c'è un paradosso
in questa situazione noi non per questo
siamo spinti ad abbandonare quello che
siamo
non per questo siamo spinti a lasciare
le nostre vere radici quindi
ricollegandoci anche un po il tema
generale di questo incontro
possiamo dire che l'uomo in realtà è una
foglia una foglia che costantemente
costantemente mette nuove radici che
radica in continuazione
vedete
dobbiamo però chiederci qual è il
terreno in cui l'uomo mette radici
perché il terreno in cui l'uno l'uomo
mette radici non è quello della nostra
cultura locale o della nostra tradizione
o almeno non lo è totalmente la nostra
cultura locale le nostre tradizioni si
muovono mutano costantemente non sono
mai le stesse muoiono rinascono cambiano
stanno assopite per un po di tempo così
come i concetti che noi crediamo più
assodati e ben stabili pensate al
concetto di corpo del nostro corpo
noi in un futuro che non è troppo
lontano
saremo in grado di modificare il nostro
corpo al punto tale da renderlo
irriconoscibile
o almeno molto diverso dal corpo fragile
che abbiamo ora
e così saremo in grado di programmare il
nostro corpo né più e né meno di come
oggi noi programmiamo software e vi sto
parlando di presente
pensate al chris per cas nine non so
molti di voi magari la conosceranno
questa tecnologia si tratta di una
tecnologia che ci permette di tagliare e
di modificare il nostro dna
e così già ora di produrre produrre
bambini che sono potenzialmente immuni
da virus determinati tipi di virus o
malattie genetiche
questo poi con tutte le conseguenze
etiche che dobbiamo cominciare a
indagare però io dico che non saremo
meno umani per questo saremo avremo un
rapporto con noi stessi forse molto
diverso ma non saremo meno umani e non
saremo meno umani nemmeno quando
scompariranno sui concetti come quello
di nazione
se voi ci pensate il concetto di nazione
è un concetto che risale a pochissimo
tempo fa nei 300 mila anni di vita che
alla nostra specie
la nostra varietà homo sapiens si parla
di 500 300 anni se proprio vogliamo
allungare dilatare i tempi non saremo
meno umani quando questi concetti
scompariranno ma non lo saremo solamente
se riusciremo a capire quali sono le
nostre vere radici dove affondano
nostre vere radici le nostre vere radici
sono piantate in un terreno che è il
tempo è tutta questione di tempo vi
dicevo ma è un tempo che è molto più
lungo di quello che noi siamo soli di
considerare è un tempo che affonda le
sue origini a quel primo uomo che
preferì vivere per terra sulla
terraferma piuttosto che sugli alberi a
quei primi uomini calzarlo lo sguardo al
cielo e iniziarono a dare un nome alle
stelle a quei primi uomini così rumorosi
parlanti quegli esseri mai visti che per
dare un senso a quello che vedevano
intorno decisero di riempire l'universo
e la natura di simboli e così come
diceva giampà tosca che un filosofo
cecoslovacco della seconda metà del
cinquecento la nostra storia risale a
quell'uomo che per primo si pose la sua
stessa esistenza
davanti come un problema si pose la
domanda della sua stessa vita ed è una
domanda affascinante forse irrisolvibile
ma è proprio in questa domanda che
stanno le nostre radici e nella
meraviglia che deriva da questa domanda
nella ricerca che deriva da questa
domanda nella fatica e nella
perseveranza
quindi la storia della nostra specie sta
tutta qui e nelle idee che noi ci siamo
portati dietro modificate dalla prova
del tempo quindi quello che ora noi
possiamo fare come specie e cercare di
diffonderle queste idee per arrivare più
preparati a un futuro che ci pone di
fronte domande che sono davvero davvero
insolite e che ci fai ci obbliga a fare
i conti con noi stessi con un nuovo se
che noi
d'ora in poi dovremmo cominciare a
indagare quindi quello che possiamo fare
per riuscire a immaginare un mondo che
sia un po più simile a quelle idee
perfette che non abitano tra di noi e
condividere dialogare e soltanto
attraverso questo dialogo questa
condivisione che noi riusciremo a
immaginare ea creare il nostro futuro
grazie
[Applauso]